welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Thomas pogi the
lightener professor of philosophy and
international affairs at Yale professor
pogi is a political philosopher who has
published widely on can't and in moral
and political philosophy including books
on John Rawls and global justice in fact
his book world poverty and human rights
is widely regarded as one of the most
important works on global justice
professor pogi is with us today to talk
about a nonprofit organization he leads
called incentives for global health and
its new flagship proposal the health
impact fund welcome professor pogi thank
you very much let's begin by talking
about incentives for global health what
is it and what was the catalyst behind
it it's basically a nonprofit
organization that consists of a bunch of
very interdisciplinary bunch of
international experts who have one
connection or another with global public
health and the purpose is really to try
to find ways of improving global public
health in order to help especially
people who are because of poverty unable
to get the medicines they need or an
increased risk of falling prior to
various kinds of diseases and one of the
initiatives to come out of the igh is
the health impact fund tell me about it
now the health impact fund is our
flagship proposal basically it's an idea
about how one can overcome this
perennial dilemma that people have been
struggling with for so many years which
you might call the access versus
innovation dilemma the dilemma is that
with new medicines in order to
incentivize pharmaceutical companies to
develop them in the first place you have
to give them some reward and the way
it's now organized the reward is patent
protection so that these companies have
a limited time in which they can market
their medicines exclusively nobody else
gets to sell that medicine and so these
companies have essentially a temporary
monopoly where they can market at a
price they wish and through this very
high mark
between the cost and the price of the
medicine they can then recuperate
recover the costs that went into
development of the medicine the research
and the development now the problem with
that is obvious at least one problem
with it is very obvious that is that
during the time that the new medicine is
under patent poor people can't get it
and poor people in this case includes
about eighty percent of the world's
population because these new medicines
tend to be quite expensive and so think
of second-line aids therapies for
example that cost anywhere from eight
hundred dollars to five thousand dollars
even in developing countries and poor
people died because they can't get
access to these medicines okay so why
does the world need the health impact
fund I mean why should we care well the
health impact fund is a very intelligent
way of solving that problem and
essentially the idea is this if you
think about poor people who now do not
have access to these medicines it
doesn't really cost anything to allow
these people to participate if we give
these people access to medicines at cost
nobody would lose anything the problem
is that if we really did that we would
undermine the temporary monopoly of the
developers of the innovators in the rich
countries because many of these drugs
would find their way back into the rich
countries and so firms in the end could
not recover their research and
development expenses and would then not
engage in the development of new
medicines so the solution that we are
proposing is to make these medicines
available for cheap to everyone rich and
poor alike and to fund the research and
development of new medicines differently
namely through the text system and the
way we picture that and here's where the
health impact fund comes in is as a
voluntary option for innovators
innovators get the option to register
any new medicine with the health impact
fund and that involves two things on the
one hand they promised to make the
medicine available at cost anywhere
wherever it may be needed on the other
hand they get a reward that is
determined by the hell
impact global health impact of the
medicine so especially for high-impact
medicines like these second line aid
therap Ed's therapies but also for drugs
like malaria drugs and so on companies
would choose the health impact fund
because they would actually make more
money for developing a new medicine than
they would on the traditional pattern
track and you would have the problem
solved because you would get innovation
companies would want to make new
medicines for the health impact run
track and you would also solve the
access problem because these medicines
would be immediately available at cost
and that is to say cheaper even then
they would be under generic production
so how will the health impact fund be
managed you'd basically have an
international agency like we are
familiar with various other
international agencies like the World
Bank the World Health Organization maybe
something along the lines of the Global
Fund would also be possible and that
agency would essentially have three
different sub organizations within it
one would determine the rules according
to which the fund operates and divides
in particular the reward money the
reward money is an annual pool of
rewards and companies would get paid out
of that reward pool for ten consecutive
years the first ten years that their
medicine is on the market so that is the
first the setting the rules deciding how
we measure health impact and how we set
up the fund and so on the second branch
would be a kind of assessment branch
which would apply these rules to the
various medicines that innovators choose
to register with the health impact fund
and that would be people who would go
out in the developing countries and also
the developed countries of course and
look at empirically what sort of an
impact that medicine has very important
thought here is that up to now
pharmaceutical innovators have been paid
for selling their drug on the health
impact run track they would be rewarded
for the drugs actually having an impact
beyond the point of sale it's not enough
to sell you have to make sure that the
drug actually reaches people who can
benefit
from it and has the desired impact on
those people and that's what triggers
the reward okay and how will it actually
be measured how will the impact be
measured well there are two parts to
that question the first is what is the
metric what is the yardstick by which we
measure impact and here we will go for a
version of what's called the quality the
quality adjusted life year so
essentially you look at how many extra
years of life human beings gained by
having the medicine available to them
and you also look at the quality
improvement of the years that people
live so sometimes a drug does not extend
life but just improves its quality and
that gets measured so for example the
quality of your life might go from
eighty percent to one hundred percent
and if so then five years of improved
quality is worth one extra year of fully
healthy life so Qualys are a way of
integrating a measure of the quality of
life with a measure for the length of
life and then measuring on that basis
now the other aspect is how do we apply
that yardstick and that's of course very
difficult as you can imagine because
especially in developing country
settings it's very difficult to keep
track of what exactly people suffer from
and what they die from and so on and
essentially we have to rely here on
three types of data the first set of
data comes out of clinical trials where
we just know in theory from these
clinical trials that this medicine can
do a lot of good for patients if they
take it correctly if they really have
the disease and so on the second is that
we will trace particular medicines down
the pipeline and see where they actually
end up so will require registering firms
to label their packages with a number
that allows us randomly to select a
certain number of batches or packages
tracing down the pipeline and C would
actually happen to them who took the
medicine did they get better how much
better did they get and so on and to do
a statistical analysis of that and then
the third way of doing it is we take
advantage of an enterprise that is now
in full swing it started at Harvard is
now moved mostly to Seattle
where the Gates Foundation is located
and that is the global burden of disease
they have a big study trying to figure
out exactly where what does the greatest
damage to global health and so they have
already a very sophisticated analysis
also in qualities of the burden of
disease which diseases cause the
greatest burden where do they cause that
burden and so on and we can use these
data to correlate with our sales data
and figure out to what extent is for
example when more drugs of particular
type went to Uganda than to Kenya we
would expect a more favorable
development of the target disease in
Uganda than in Kenya and so by
correlating data about sales and data
about the evolution of the global
disease burden we can make statistical
estimates of how much the medicine had
to do with the way the disease burden
develops so these are the three sources
empirical sources of data okay and what
is the status of the health impact fund
today well we don't have it up and
running yet we have I'm working with a
team as I said which is about a dozen
people a few more perhaps and one Keith
team members Eden hollis who's an
economist at the University of Calgary
whom I've been working with very
intensively the two of us together we're
lead authors on a book that we've just
done which was finished in the middle of
August so it's a very recent development
150 page book which you can download
from the ww health impact fund org
website and in that book we have
essentially laid out the basics of the
health impact fund how it would work and
so forth now that work is not complete
we still need further experts to weigh
in and help us with various questions
that we are not very comfortable
answering ourselves for example health
impact assessment at the population
level often when some people get
healthier in the case of a communicable
disease that brings advantages to other
people so we need epidemiologists to
help us figure out what that population
level impact is and so on so it's a work
in progress we are still trying to
develop it but the greatest hurdle of
course is the political hurdle we have
to get governments interested and
excited in that project and as you can
imagine in politics everybody knows
there's a problem lots and lots of
people are suffering and dying from
relatively trivial diseases but it's
also true that many many people have
some answer or another to this problem
and so we have to try to get governments
to focus on this answer because the most
sophisticates actually the best answer
to this problem or so we think and we
have to find political support for it
and so we have in the moment a series of
high-level meetings in different
countries trying to get the Europeans
and the Americans interested in it one
meeting was just in Oslo in August will
have a very major event planned at
Georgetown University on the first of
December where we try to get a number of
principles from the Congress involved
some high level politicians but also
people from the health agencies let such
as the NIH and so on and discuss it in a
very high level also very important are
the pharmaceutical companies and of
course NGOs patients groups so you can
imagine they are various stakeholders
and one of the things that makes the
health impact fund proposal particularly
promising is that it's really a
win-win-win-win proposal it's no group
really loses in any major way and that's
possible for the reason that I gave
earlier that it costs nothing to include
poor people in new medicines that we are
developing anyway okay so as you pointed
out the hif is clearly a work in
progress ultimately how will you measure
its success it's actually quite simple
because the health impact fund itself is
an assessment mechanism it includes a
very important assessment component so
if the health impact fund gets up it
will assess the impact of the various
drugs that are registered with it and
then you can use these assessments to
assess the health impact fund itself you
can say the aggregate health impact of
all the registered drugs was such and so
and you can figure out what the reward
rate is each year namely how many
dollars where
paid for each quality that collectively
the registered medicines achieved okay
well thank you very much for sharing
some of your innovative work with us
today for more information about
professor pogi including his newest book
on the IHF please visit our website at
yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale